l'élection présidentielle ce qu'a
confirmé jean-yves le drian ce matin sur
france inter on écoute le ministre des
affaires étrangères il apparaît très
clairement pour tout le monde y compris
pour tous les européens qu'il est
nécessaire de sortir de cette crise par
une élection qui soit complètement
légitime et qui soit complètement
vérifier une élection présidentielle
parce que c'est un régime présidentiel
c'est ce que nous avons demandé et nous
allons maintenant prendre les
dispositions nécessaires puisque il ya
ce refus de la part du président de
maduro alors évidemment le président
obama nous rhône n'a pas du tout la même
lecture que jean yves le drian
il l'a fait savoir hier sur la chaîne de
télévision espagnole la sexta
je ne refuse pas une élection il y aura
déjà une présidentielle en 2024
cela nous importe peu ce que dit l'union
européenne au venezuela que l'europe
s'occupe de ses problèmes le chômage la
crise économique l'immigration
mais qui peut dire dans le monde qu'il
faut élire en violation du droit
international et sans poser un pays qui
a déjà une conception indépendante de
son modèle politique il a pas
foncièrement tort si auprès d'eux si la
question c'est devions nous reconnaître
le président gazeau comme le nouveau
président par intérim
la réponse est oui enfin pour moi tous
les feux sont au vert d'abord on
reconnaît un président par intérim c'est
à dire qu'en fait on pas rennes plus un
processus qu'on a double une
personnalité qui serait arrivé au
pouvoir en dehors des urnes
bon on sait
comment le président m'a d'euros est
arrivé aux hurle 68 ou 70% des voix si
je ne m'abuse l'opposition refusant de
participer au scrutin
bon donc manifestement un problème
démocratique il ya une semble-t-il un
processus qui se met en place
on dit ben on reconnaît ce processus à
travers celui qui est capable de le
mener on n'est pas les seuls on a avec
nous un certain nombre de pays dont
d'ailleurs le canada on a sur place si
je peux dire en face sur le continent
et voilà donc moi ça me paraît
parfaitement parfaitement équilibré
juste comme comme lorient seulement pas
et c'est très ennuyeux pour la
diplomatie française en général qui perd
si j'allais dire des parts de marché un
peu partout dans le monde entier à part
un fédération a fait inféodation aux
états unis je vais demander froidement
sans défendre maduro et d'ailleurs je ne
pense pas que le rôle d'un président
soin de juger s'il précis à présent
d'autres pays est bon ou mauvais c'est
se trouvent les très mauvais il est nul
en économie et une partie de son de son
une forte corruption
mais dans quelle manière cela justifie
que la france se mêle d'élections ça
s'appelle une ingérence en général ça
mène à des catastrophes
et puis on ne peut pas utiliser les
droits de l'homme comme on le fait à ce
point en occident est maintenant en
particulier en france comme outil
géopolitique soit on les défend et on
les défend absolument et on devient
champion à l'onu de cela onu qui soit
dit en passant ont reconnu l'élection de
grille demain donc là on est dans un va
à l'encontre de l'onu donc un problème
et imaginons mal egypte alors et puis
ben salman l'arabie saoudite et puis la
guerre au yémen
et puis le honduras pourquoi ne reconnut
un coup d'état au honduras soit plus de
600 700 intellectuelle profession mais
il ya un souci soit non mais pourquoi
et là je pose la question est ce que tu
es politiques mais partout en egypte il
n'aura en algérie si vous pensez que les
élections algériennes avec bouteflika
qui en semi momie va être réélu on ne
sait pourquoi on ne sait comment sera
démocratiquement à 106 me commencer
quelque part vous devez le faire
ailleurs et vous amis oui mais il ya eu
les élections ne m'attendais que j'ai
juste avant d'aller la parole à
christoph daum juste le tweed emmanuel
macron qui va dans le sens de ce que
vous visiez pas de ce que vous dénonciez
je vous lis le tweed emmanuel macron qui
est là qu il a écrit tout à l'heure les
vénézuéliens ont le droit de s'exprimer
librement et démocratiquement
la france reconnaît juan garrido comme
président en charge pour mettre en
oeuvre un processus électoral nous
soutenons le groupe de contact créé avec
l'union européenne
dans cette période de transition c'est
la bonne la mairie bras on peut discuter
à l'infini sur sur le droit
international dans cette affaire mais je
remarque qu'il est difficile de
condamner les lpd en france et est
d'accepter un régime qui me tirent à
balles réelles sur des manifestants
donc ça c'est un problème de cohérence
mais surtout il ya une vraie raison pour
laquelle on doit intervenir ou comme on
le fait je dis bien c'est à dire par un
processus international il ya une vraie
raison c'est que la crise vénézuélienne
est devenue une crise internationale ce
qui n'est pas le cas des autres pays que
vous avez mentionné
c'est à dire que c'est en egypte y'a pas
de crise internationale autour de
l'egypte tandis que là vous avez des
millions de vénézuéliens
l'amusant qui nous parlent de nos
problèmes d'immigration ce qui à gauche
de gauche française ne dit pas
généralement en france qu'on a des
problèmes d'immigration enfin c'est
toujours intéressant
lui il a des problèmes des migrations
massives autrement dit les deux trains
c'est en train de déstabiliser toute la
région
regardez bien ce qui se passe en
colombie par exemple et ces désordres
n'oublions jamais c'est la raison
fondamentale pour laquelle l'ordre
international doit doit intervenir parce
que il ya une déstabilisation du fait de
la situation intérieure au venezuela
alors juste avant que je donne ma parole
mais avec ma question il peut le faire
mais tes skis sont au fond est-ce qu'on
fait pas le jeu
des états unis de donald trump qui a dit
sur une chaîne de télévision américaine
que l'envoi de troupes militaires était
une option est ce que du coup on n'est
pas dans la route avec la crainte de
devoir nous aussi envoyer des troupes
non je pense que là c'est pas du tout
envisagée mais elle cesserait c'est une
réponse indirecte à ce que ce que vous
disiez s'il y avait une unanimité ou en
tout cas une très grande majorité y
compris même au sein de l'europe de
l'opinion internationale sur le
processus qu'il faut enfin l'attitude
qu'il faut avoir face aux processus
vénézuélien ça serait tout à fait
acceptable parce que vous dites mais il
ya quand même beaucoup de pays qui sont
absolument pas sur cette position alors
je parle pas évidemment des prix georges
chine russie et autres qui soutiennent
le président en place mais même au sein
de l'europe la situation est loin d'être
de faire l'unanimité et donc et puis
vous avez des pays mais pardonnez moi
mais le brésil qu'on a accusé de tous
les maux pour son président qui a été
accusée par lui comme étant le pire des
populistes et aux soutiens donc le
candidat que nous sommes censés soutenir
donc tout ça est un peu compliquée moi
j'ai un principe peut-être trop simple
parce que je ne suis qu'historien donc
je ne suis pas vous faites des affaires
internationales mais je pense que les
principes de droit d'ingérence n'ont pas
véritablement montré dans les vingt
dernières années leur efficacité je
crois que c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
est donc faudrait peut-être un petit peu
arrêté voilà merci à tous les quatre ans
je pense qu'on reviendra sur ce débat
dans l'est dans les jours et les
semaines à venir l'émission est terminée
j'étais ravie de la présenter avec vous
et je vous donne rendez vous demain pour
la l'émission point de vue qui sera
présentée par marie amélie lombard
passer une bonne soirée
[Musique]